sí muy buenos días bueno pues este
consejo está ciento por ciento enfocado
precisamente en esta pandemia de
coronavirus en donde los casos siguen
repuntando aquí en francia en las
últimas 24 horas se llegó a 10.000 casos
en el país algo que no se había
reportado desde el comienzo de esta
crisis sanitaria en la mesa de de marzo
el presidente de manuel marco dijo en la
noche de este jueves que lo que quiere
es dar más visibilidad a cómo va a ser
la vida en las próximas semanas y que
por eso se están reuniendo el día de hoy
además de esto el consejo científico que
es el que viene asesorando el gobierno
nacional en cuanto a todos estos temas
de la corona virus ha dicho que el
gobierno va a tener que tomar decisiones
difíciles esas decisiones que además van
a tener una repercusión tan sólo en unos
10 a 15 días así que el gobierno lo que
quiere evitar a todo precio es un nuevo
confinamiento general pero si es posible
que ahora digamos le pasen las
responsabilidades más a los territorios
a las autoridades locales para que sean
ellas las que determinen si va a haber
por ejemplo confinamientos a nivel local
cambiar por ejemplo
árido de apertura de lugares que
atiendan a público y también haya quizás
restricciones al desplazamiento de las
personas sobre todo en las zonas que
están en digamos alerta roja por el gran
número de casos italia pero cuéntenos
además cuáles serían las medidas
principales que deberían o podrían
anunciarse durante esta jornada por
parte del gobierno
así después se espera que esos anuncios
sean ya caída esta tarde será o lidia
con el ministro de salud quien haga
estos anuncios ante los franceses hay
dos decisiones principales por una parte
recortar el tiempo de la cuarentena que
pasaría de 14 días a 7 días esto porque
ya digamos que a partir del octavo día
una persona no es contagiosa en todo
caso eso fue lo que dijo el consejo
científico y eso también permitiría que
la gente cumpliera más con esta medida
de aislamiento algo que no está
sucediendo porque en francia no se está
rompiendo la cadena de contagio y por
otra parte la idea es también hacer unos
tests que sean mucho más prioritarios
para las personas que tienen síntomas y
también para las personas que han estado
en contacto con alguien que haya dado
positivo estos textos son diferentes de
los tests moleculares del pce que
ustedes conocen y que es la prueba de
antigénico una prueba que es mucho más
rápida porque el resultado se obtiene en
tan solo 15 a 20 minutos y permite de
esta manera puedes hacer unos tests
mucho más importantes a nivel nacional
así que éstas serían digamos las dos
medidas más importantes que se espera se
anuncian el día de hoy
por ahora se sabe que estos test anti
higiénicos deberían ponerse en marcha en
todo caso aquí en isla de francia que es
el departamento que alberga a parís pero
es también posible que sea una medida
para el resto del país
natalia ruiz nuestra periodista en parís